here we are at Hollywood Sports Park big
thanks to those guys for letting us play
on their off date because look at this
we're in a graveyard
check this up because this is the
graveyard we figured why not play some
zombie action the idea is to remain
human until you are the last man
standing once you are that person you
have won but the game's not over until
you are dead
everyone in their starting spot I'm
going to stick with you guys oh you look
dangerous you are all really trusty
immerse now to call me hey sure is hot
out here I was feeling a little air I
got to tell you all right the game has
just started whoever is a zombie has 30
seconds to reveal himself a for loop
here but right now I don't rip come down
here okay everybody I got your back okay
right it's been 30 seconds if you're the
zombie you better drop your weapon
[Applause]
okay
/ glass slab filled it up now building
up their worries how to get up to the
second floor and hold my ground I have
to get there here's okay hold our ground
up here
oh boy
it's only got wanna know how to get up
here I think this is all me behind this
wall
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
jumping off the balcony night mr.
disclose that this is a sponsored video
I trained my beard when I got back from
Europe euros my beard was as big as game
I know L suppose we get a trimmer but I
have such confidence in sixth place that
this will be painless and easy
I don't always shave my beard but when I
do I prefer a flexible delivery schedule
thankfully Dollar Shave Club gives me
that and an amazing shave at the same
time with an affordable price I'm
general Carmichael I just came here from
the Civil War something really cool
about Dollar Shave Club is that no
hidden fees
you can cancel whenever you want and
it's actually a decent affordable price
[Music]
wouldn't that goatee in that hat all he
needs now is a Harley I think all the
ladies are gonna love this one is a
little whiskers right there I'm gonna
FaceTime my girlfriend hi hey babe I'm
gonna get rid of the moustache if I went
to the gym like this I would look like a
pervert you won't look just like me have
some sweet shaving gear first link below
will give you a one-month free trial
save time save money should I shave it
let me know in the comments below
Oh